el alcalde de una ciudad leyó un
artículo el cual sostenía que la tasa de
desempleo a nivel nacional es del 8%
para determinar si eso también aplica en
su ciudad tomó una muestra de 200
residentes para probar su hipótesis nula
la cual establece que la tasa de
desempleo es igual a la tasa a nivel
nacional contra la hipótesis alternativa
en la cual se establece que la tasa de
desempleo es diferente a la que ocurre a
nivel nacional donde p es la proporción
de residentes en la ciudad que están
desempleados la muestra incluyó 22
residentes desempleados supongo que se
cumplen las condiciones para la
inferencia es decir que la muestra es
aleatoria normal y cumple la condición
de independencia lo que hemos mencionado
en vídeos anteriores y establece el
estadístico adecuado para esta prueba de
significancia voy a escribir lo que
tenemos para asegurarme de que
entendemos lo que sucede tenemos una
hipótesis nula que dice que la
proporción real de desempleados en la
ciudad eso es lo que representa p es la
misma que ocurre a nivel nacional
recuerden que la hipótesis nula
establece el caso en el que no hay
cambios
nada nuevo nada que informar por así
decirlo y tenemos la hipótesis
alternativa es decir la proporción real
de desempleo en la ciudad es distinta a
8% lo que hacemos ahora es fijar un
nivel de significancia suponemos que el
alcalde lo fijó digamos que él o ella
establecieron el nivel de significancia
en 0.05 entonces lo que hacemos es
realizar el experimento esta es la
población total de la ciudad tomaron una
muestra de 200 personas esta es nuestra
muestra n es igual a 200 dado que se
cumple la condición de independencia
suponemos que esto es menos del 10% de
la población calculamos un estadístico
muestral y dado que nos interesa el
valor real de la proporción el
estadístico muestral que nos interesa es
la proporción muestral así calculamos
que 22 de 200 personas en la muestra
están desempleadas esto es igual a 0.11
ahora suponiendo que la hipótesis nula
es verdadera cuál es la probabilidad de
obtener un resultado que se encuentra
así o más alejado de la proporción
poblacional
si esa probabilidad es menor que alfa
rechazaremos la hipótesis lo que
sugerirá la validez de la hipótesis
alternativa como encontramos esta
probabilidad una manera de ver esto es
preguntarse a cuantas desviaciones
estándar del valor real de la proporción
del valor que hemos supuesto para la
proporción se encuentra la proporción
que obtuvimos de la muestra entonces
calculamos la probabilidad de obtener
ese número de desviaciones estándar o
más con respecto al valor real de la
proporción queremos entonces obtener el
número de desviaciones estándar ese será
un estadístico z el cual calculamos como
la diferencia entre la proporción
muestral y el valor supuesto de la
proporción poblacional esto es 0 punto
11 - 0.08 dividido entre la desviación
estándar de la distribución la cual
podemos calcular recuerden que aunque en
general desconocemos la proporción
poblacional en este caso estamos
suponiendo que es 0.08 lo cual tenemos
que multiplicar por 1 menos 0.08 tenemos
que multiplicarlo por 0 punto
2 esto viene de lo que hemos visto en
vídeos anteriores la desviación estándar
de la distribución muestral de
proporciones dividimos esto entonces
entre n que en este caso es 200 podemos
sacar una calculadora para obtener este
valor el cual nos indicará a cuántas
desviaciones estándar se encuentra 0.11
de 0.08 con la ayuda de una tabla zeta
podemos obtener cuál es la probabilidad
de un valor que se encuentra a ese
número de desviaciones estándar o más
con respecto a la proporción poblacional
lo cual nos dará el valor p para
compararlo con el nivel de significancia
esto podemos escribirlo en general con
la siguiente fórmula la diferencia entre
la proporción muestral y la proporción
poblacional que se establece en la
hipótesis nula esto es lo que indica
este subíndice 0 y eso lo dividimos
entre la desviación estándar de la
distribución muestral de proporciones la
cuál es la proporción poblacional que se
establece en la hipótesis nula por 1 -
dicha proporción poblacional dividido
entre el tamaño de la muestra en futuros
vídeos continuaremos el ejercicio para
calcular
el valor de z el cual ubicamos en una
tabla z para determinar la probabilidad
de obtener un valor que sea así o más
extremo y compararlo con alfa nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo